hier matin villers-cotterêts à 80 km de
paris avec une révolution sous les pas
de cet ancien militaire il y a encore
une semaine cet homme pressé n'était
qu'un inconnu
aujourd'hui il est entouré d'une dizaine
de journalistes comme d'habitude
dynamique
ils courent savourer sa revanche normal
ça l'est pas aujourd'hui
cela faisait dix neuf ans qu'il rêvait
de devenir le maire de cette ville de
10000 habitants au nord de paris
dimanche dernier il a enfin remporté la
victoire
il n'a pas conquis la plus grande ville
de france
mais c'est tout de même un moment
historique
franck briffaut est le premier maire
front national jamais élu en picardie
mon équipe et moi même avons clairement
affiché ce que nous sommes mais nous
serons les élus de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
et cela quelle que soit leur origine
leurs croyances et leurs convictions
politiques élus au 2e tour avec 41% des
voix le maire fn ne fait pas l'unanimité
c'est pourtant lui qui va diriger la
ville pendant six ans comme franck
briffaut ils sont douze candidats du
front national à avoir remporté une
mairie en france le chiffre peut
paraître dérisoire mais c'est la
première fois que ce parti s'impose avec
un tel bilan
non
et il faut aussi y ajouter près de 1200
conseillers municipaux
la percée du front national a de quoi
réjouir sa présidente pendant 15 jours
nous avons suivi la campagne de deux
candidats dans les bouches du rhône où
le parti a réalisé ses plus gros scores
adrien mexys a débarqué à istres il y a
6 mois
il veut rassembler autour de lui les
déçus du système je pense exactement
comme adrien mexys et au mali valérie
lopy directrice d'école à tarascon elle
profite de sa notoriété pour attirer
même ce qu'on attendait pas il peut
voter et ben bouzid qui veut être la
maîtresse d'accord quelles sont leurs
méthodes pour séduire le plus grand
nombre
quel est le vrai visage de ces nouveaux
élus à istres dans les bouches du rhône
un candidat front national tente de se
faire connaître mais on continue c'est
là normalement voilà cinq cents il
s'appelle adrien mexys il a 33 ans c'est
sa première campagne électorale ce matin
avec son équipe il va faire du porte à
porte dans cette cité de la ville
donc on va voir si la démocratie est la
bienvenue ici a priori si son parti est
indésirable non 0 adrien mexys et son
équipe sont vite repérés
ouais pourquoi pourquoi un
l'opération va tourner court
1 qu'est ce qu'ils disent du côté du
mans contre adrien mexys et son équipe
sans qu'ils ne peuvent rester plus
longtemps dans le quartier ils
rebroussent chemin
pourquoi quel est le problème je roule
désormais si j'aurais fait pour nous le
veut nous vu comme ça que je suis
raciste au contraire à ces chercheurs
ont mené son poids deux mesures
non juste des gens sont leurs mérites
pas sur leur origine
d'ailleurs il ya des gens d'origines
aussi de toutes origines sur notre liste
monsieur vous regardez il tente de
poursuivre sa tournée mais on lui jette
un caillou voilà c'est bien c'est
courageux ça bravo le candidat bat en
retraite et il reçoit un autre
projectile en guise d'adieu
c'est bien bravo
oui j'ai des cailloux gros c'est là on a
vu trois quatre personnes
je pense qu'on va effectivement
on va aller dans un quartier on peut
faire de la politique
si demain vous êtes maire vous fait quoi
quand vis-à-vis de ces gens là ah bon et
on les contrôles ont fait respecter la
loi tout simplement comme en bas c'est
la police municipale à faire son nom
ouais là on voit bien que les
attroupements donc que c'est illégal
intro d'autres mauvaises surprises
attend d'adrien mexys au cours de cette
campagne et il y en a une qui l'agacent
particulièrement des habitants s'en
prenne à ses affiches électorales
ils ont cartonné encore c'est dingue
iyaz en fait ils viennent des petites
boulettes sur un autre panneau un
vandale l'affubler d'un petit mot doux
ah bah voilà
ah oui d'accord ccja marqué la marque
ebit d'accord la classe on voit le
niveau et le 3 non plus n'y est plus je
prends à chaque fois qu'il est victime
de ce genre d' attaque
adrien mexys l'exploitent immédiatement
sur internet m'a lâché en train de le
mettre directement sur le blog et il
retourne la situation à son avantage
c'est pour montrer que nous sommes
vraiment ce qui dérange quand vous
voulez voir ce qui dérange pas il suffit
de venir devant un panneau d'affichage
et vous vous voyez qui met le doigt sur
les problèmes parce qu'il y'a que la
vérité qui blesse
les dégâts sont aussitôt effacé
la campagne électorale coûte cher aux
jeunes candidats qui ne touchent pas un
centime du front national
c'est moi qui finance tout à bien la
campagne là pour l'instant ça me coûte
35000 euros quand même donc oui ça coûte
très cher heureusement que j'ai
travaillé les années précédentes et que
j'ai économisé parce que c'est sûr que
pour pas vous louper il a dû aussi faire
un prêt s'il obtient 5% des voix
ses frais de campagne nuit seront
remboursés le pari est osé
adrià mexys a renoncé une carrière toute
tracée sciences po hec puis un poste de
haut fonctionnaire européen qu'il a
abandonné pour tenter de ravir istres
une ville de 45000 habitants où il n'y a
pas eu de liste fn depuis 20 ans pour y
parvenir il a constitué une équipe du
cousin est en porte à porte et est plus
à l'aise en distribution et toi corinne
et des bénévoles qui connaissent bien le
terrain
aucun quartier de la ville ne leur
échappe lennar 6 sur 6 500 car c'est un
quartier qu'il faut qu'on contracte ça
aussi mais en politique
la plupart sont des novices concert les
deux pour composer sa liste
adria mexys a donc fait appel à toutes
les personnes de bonne volonté comme
véronique deuxième de son équipe
une ancienne écologistes passé récemment
au front national
sa priorité si elle est élue ce n'est
pas de fliquer la ville mais de
contrôler les assiettes des cantines
scolaires
j'ai remis de tenir mes promesses voilà
et avoir donc avoir du bios nice
assiette développer plutôt les
agricultures l'agriculture que du
bétonnage
voilà vous avez vous avez chiffré tout
ça pour votre parti
non il ya 17 pour l'instant tout ce
qu'elle a évalué c'est que la commune
pouvait économiser 10 mille euros par an
en supprimant les pesticides et qu'on
pouvait rejeter un peu moins de gaz
carbonique en achetant des produits
locaux d'autres comme alain se sentent
suffisamment expérimenté pour gérer une
ville comme istres j'ai géré des camps
de vacances donc assez important j'ai
fait je suis un homme de terrain
c'est sur le terrain que je me suis fait
entre parenthèses il ya encore tout
avoir
bon forcément là qui est acquis il ya
encore avoir à faire c'est donc avec une
équipe de poids légers qu'adrien mexys
va tenter de convaincre les électeurs
parmi les autres villes qui espèrent
conquérir le front national il y à aussi
tarascon une commune de 14 mille
habitants où la candidate fn valérie
lopy ne supporte plus de voir l'état du
centre ville bon ça non plus je trouve
pas ça génial des grandes culottes des
grandes je sais pas quoi aux fenêtres
je pense que c'est quand même pas très
chouette de détendre c'est enfin toutes
ses sous vêtements est en tout cas moi
ça me donnerait pas d'aidé à 24 heures
du premier tour aller cette femme de 48
ans veut convaincre les derniers indécis
je suis madame lopy candidate aux
élections municipales peut-être que vous
avez déjà vu ma tête quelque part entre
8 heures et 18 heures vous allez mettre
un bulletin dans l'urne pour moi je
m'appelle valérie l'opus vous laisse
tout ça comme ça vous verrez que je mens
pas par rapport aux logements sociaux
merci à vous merci aussi à l'est des
logements sociaux
valérie l'opinion promet à tous ceux qui
veulent bien quitter le centre ville de
tarascon
habitée majoritairement par des familles
d'origine maghrébine et gitane autrefois
animé le coeur historique a perdu de sa
superbe
le patrimoine s'est dégradée de nombreux
commerces ont fermé et la paupérisation
est grandissante encore de magnifiques
chênes de poubelles 1 on était ce une
erreur parce qu'en plus c'est les odeurs
sa formidable ça il faut que ce soit
plus propre à on n'est pas des rats
voilà la candidate veut redynamiser le
quartier ou plutôt leur et embourgeoisée
comme elle dit l'objectif c'est
d'inviter les gens qui n'ont pas un
logement salubre qu'à prendre un
logement social en périphérie je pense
que les derniers arrivés comme je les
appelle qui n'ont pas forcément le même
mode culturel que les français et quand
un touriste vient à tarascon eh bien il
veut voir la provence il veut voir la
france et ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement de faire partir le mode de
vie orientale du centre-ville tout à
fait c'est exactement ça ouais tout à
fait un discours qui fait mouche chez
certains habitants du quartier
toulouse qui déposait plainte de 8 x
pour menace de mort ça francis
descazeaux a carrément d'accord
du coup j'imagine que vous allez voter
dimanche pour moi bah goûter c'est clair
et net
je vous souhaite bon courage je vous
remercie beaucoup madame c'est touchant
le plus étonnant c'est que la candidate
front national récolte aussi des voix là
où on ne l'attend pas car valérie loupé
un atout elle est directrice dans une
école publique et bonjour votre gros
elle enseigne depuis 20 ans un parcours
sans faute qui lui donne du crédit ou
voter dimanche
même auprès d'une population qui
pourrait rejeter ses idées bonjour
monsieur je les connais vos enfants des
écoles smaïn
il peut voter et ben bouzid qui va être
pour la maîtresse d'accord vous allez
voter pour elle parce que 6 mois minimum
et la libye et vous savez quel écran le
front national arrive qu'elles sont
allées à donner je remercie beaucoup
c'est quand même étonnant vous arriver
comment récupérer des électeurs là où je
ne crois que parfois ils me disent voilà
pour mes enfants je voterai pour vous
les gens ils en ont marre d'entendre
qu'on serait des méchants a priori et
raciste des racines je veux dire quand
on les côtoie ans vit avec eux ils
voient bien que je suis rien de tout ce
qu'on dit coucou mais cette image de
maîtresses bienveillante ne serait-elle
qu'un vernis mais car lorsque la
candidate discute loin de notre caméra
avec une commerçante
ces propos sont beaucoup plus crue mois
la dernière fois je me rappelle j'ai été
fondre sur le marché une nappe qui
faisait un peu provençal et bien c'est
un arabe qui font qu'un oui il avait
rien de provençal ce que je fais quand
on voit la bande noire
bonjour vous allez bien aller ce double
discours
l'adversaire de valérie lopy le divers
droite lucien limousin le dénonça le
tram avec une belle gueule avec un beau
sourire mais par contre après on
s'aperçoit que
il ya une façade mais que le fond reste
le même elle défend des idées qui pour
moi sont conformes à tous que le front
national a pu faire jusqu'à maintenant
pourtant valérie lopy avec son joli
sourire n'a pas toujours soutenu le
front national et la même combattu chez
les lobbys difficile d'imaginer que
valérie et son mari frédéric ont
longtemps voté à gauche dans leur
passion pour le front national s'affiche
dans la maison
[Musique]
comme nous pensons souvent à eux
eh bien on les a mis son frigo si vous
m'aviez dit il ya dix ans tu défendrait
jean marie le pen mais j'aurais dit ça
va pas du tout le pen il fallait passer
le pas n'était pas facile j'avais
l'image d'abrutis qui qui qui qui était
raciste des pluies qui était de
primaires car au départ la jeune
institutrice a le coeur plutôt à gauche
comme ses parents dans cette famille il
n'y avait qu'une seule possibilité on
pouvait être que de gauche sinon l'été
qu'on n'était pas le coach c'est comme
ça égoïste
ça c'était l'époque de en août à gauche
a ses opinions politiques vire à droite
après avoir lu des discours de
jean-marie le pen et de sa fille marine
c'est ce livre qui m'a fait passer au
front national
j'ai bien aimé sa façon de voir j'ai
l'impression de penser la même chose
qu'elle plus tôt son mari est lui aussi
attiré par le front national et ils
annoncent leur virage politique à leurs
familles lors d'un repas de noël en
forme a mis dans l'embarras en disant
mais valérie c'est pas possible tu vas
pas quand même c'est avec quelque chose
dont on a l'habitude c'est ce serait
honteux on s'est dit mais là c'est grave
quand même sur n'a plus le droit de
vivre un programme politique d'un jeu de
réflexion
ce rejet les énerve et ils franchissent
le pas soit arrivé à taraz ce fossé
brager sur internet en a
c'est notre cadeau puis valérie l'opic
gravi les échelons dans le parti en 2010
elle est élue conseillère régionale dans
l'école où elle enseigne son engagement
politique lui a valu les foudres de
collègues jean adam c'est vrai que c'est
là où j'ai eu quelques épreuves tout ce
qui s'est passé est bien au début j'ai
bien senti que certains enseignants
avaient peur d'être assimilé à l'école
de fachos enfin j'imagine dans leur
tatin ce qui pouvait se passer d'eux des
gens qui ne vous parlais plus habiles ya
eu à un moment oui où il y avait des
gens qui mangent tourné le dos mais ça
c'est vrai qu'au départ ça fait mal puis
après bon ben on s'habitue un petit peu
à ce genre de réaction surtout qu'elle
réussit à convaincre une partie des
électeurs de tarascon ils sont 57% avoir
voté pour elle aux législatives de 2012
et valérie lopy espère rééditer ce bon
score
dimanche 23 mars 18h30 les votes du
premier tour son terminés
je vous invite à les reporter à faire
des paquets de 10 dans les allées
frédéric le mari de valérie lopy est
parti en éclaireur dans un bureau de
vote
il veut vérifier qu'elle est la première
tendance moselle moselle lobby
ranger lobby grangier on va attendre une
centaine de longs moments de vérité
une centaine d'enveloppés au galop
frédéric alors je suis en tête à 41 42 %
sur keller bureau sans carburant au
local du front national saleri lopy
s'impatiente
elle recueille les premiers résultats
31 10 points derrière ok et quand son
mari la rejoint
il a le sourire sa femme est pour
l'instant en tête limousin 33 69 et
valérie lopy 40 25
mais bon c'est serré quand même un
sculpteur à ce qu'on y sont excellent
homme qu'une mobilisation de pareils
mais rien n'est encore joué à istres
adrian nikci se rend à la mairie pour
connaître le résultat final
partis de zéro le candidat fn espère
être encore présent au second tour
les résultats viennent de s'afficher
mexys obtient un très bon score avec ses
29 % il arrive deuxième derrière le
maire sortant à 40% comme ça ah oui la
première enveloppe j'ai dit c'est bon à
istres
jamais un candidat du fn n'avait atteint
un tel score aux municipales
certains électeurs sont sous le choc
sauriez pas complètement démonté
puis ce qu'ils ont fait à huîtres dans
la douleur marignane j'espère pas et ne
méritent pas istres
il
vous pensez que vous avez une chance de
gagner oui la france ce soir on a une
chance de gagner mais pas tous à adrien
mexys a une idée derrière la tête
s'il veut remporter la mairie au
deuxième tour il devra faire alliance
avec le candidat ump qui a obtenu 16%
des votes à tarascon valérie lopy fait
la victoire avec 39% des voix
elle arrive en tête devant lucien
limousin et ses 33 % je vais vous dire
que seul c'était impossible
c'est valérie et la liste rassemblement
bleu marine
huawei un grand grand bravo à frédéric
lopez
mais elle pense déjà au second tour dès
demain on va se remettre au travail
frédéric tu vas pouvoir faire un tract
coulé à istres aussi ont fait ce succès
[Applaudissements]
adrià mexys a réussi à séduire près d'un
votant sur 3 ha mer bleue marine je
pense que c'est possible
on l'a déjà convaincu énormément de
monde il faut voir que j'avais aucune
structure de rien de rien il ya un an
merci c'était ma première fois et
c'était et c'était bon tout est bon pour
l'emporter
il doit convaincre le candidat ump de
voter pour lui
il lui propose un rendez vous voulez
venir à la permanence d'accord très bien
dans combien de temps balla de suite
alors là dessus je vais lui dire que il
faut qu'il pense à la ville je pense
qu'on peut faire cause commune avec le
sac
un quart d'heure plus tard le candidat
ump se présente avec son équipe mais il
refuse que nous filmions les
négociations moi je peux à m'extraire là
les discussions vont se dérouler hors
caméra l'ump qui tentent de négocier
avec le fn visiblement ce n'est pas très
avouables
les candidats disparaissent pendant une
demi heure
adrien mexys fini par revenir seul et il
semble un peu contrarié
révélée avait su je pensais pas
forcément que la laisse tomber dans les
bras un c'est compliqué chacun doit
avoir de son côté mais c'est vrai que la
stratégie de mexys s'effondre il n'y
aura pas d'alliance avec l'ump qui a
reçu des consignes de paris il lui reste
une semaine pour essayer de rebondir à
tarascon le concurrent de valérie loki
lucien limousin appelle à voter contre
le front national
[Applaudissements]
l'heure est au rassemblement
la victoire que nous attendons tous la
victoire d'un front républicain et
devant les caméras de télévision qui
attaque sa rivale il a relevé d'étranges
coïncidences entre les programmes des
différents candidats front national là
c'est so les deux professions de foi une
une de nîmes une de tarasco vous prenez
au verso cinq bonnes raisons qu'il se
présente à nîmes ou à tarascon le
candidat hérite d'un programme standard
a réalisé par le fn à paris
cuir est exactement exactement le même
les mêmes programmes mettre fin aux
injustices sociales améliorée s'est
améliorée insécurité renault recto tout
est identique sauf bien sûr le nom et la
photo du candidat au verso le programme
est un copier-coller semblable à la
virgule près de nîmes c'est pourquoi
parce que en fait il ya les 36000
communes de france
elle souffre un petit peu près des mêmes
choses et effectivement il n'y a qu'une
voie et cette voix là elle est
effectivement la même pour les 36000
communes viennent et qui vous reprochent
de votre expérience
je savais qu'il étudiait la commune je
le savais je le savais je suis désolé a
pour l'instant c'est vrai que je peux
pas vous sortir des chiffres comme ça
je les suis pas ce qu'on écrit des
formations dans ça je ne suis pas
chiffres mais voilà je sais qu'il ya de
l'argent dans les caisses que je n'ai
pas du tout l'intention de la dilapider
que je suivrai pas à pas les comptes
quand j'y serai vraiment la bataille du
deuxième tour va réserver encore bien
des surprises au candidat front national
à istres sur le marché comme partout en
ville le maire sortant françois
bernardini 66 ans connaît tout le monde
merci ça va ça va bien à tel point qu'il
se permet même quelques grivoiserie
première fois font que passer avec
certaines de ses administrés merci
bonjour bonjour d'aller bien sympa comme
je vois ça j'ai je vous refais le dire
comme ça partout ah oui oui lui pour
convaincre les électeurs de voter pour
lui
le candidat de gauche ne ménage pas sa
peine il est même prêt à envoyer des
voitures pour aller chercher ceux qui
ont du mal à se déplacer pour voter
connaît j'étais vraiment
bon et ça va mieux je l'adorent pourquoi
parce qu'il m'a fait avoir un
appartement que bien des petites
attentions qui en font un homme
populaire même si par le passé françois
bernardini a été condamné à de la prison
avec sursis et à cinq ans
d'inéligibilité pour détournement de
fonds publics
aujourd'hui les casseroles semble
derrière lui un détail près des
habitants lui reproche d'avoir dilapidé
l'argent de la commune pour faire
construire cette somptueuse mairie
qu'ils appellent le palais 5000 mètres
carrés de locaux ultramodernes une
décoration contemporaine
et pour le maire un bureau spacieux avec
une terrasse donnant sur un étang d'où
jaillit le deuxième plus grand jet d'eau
d'europe
après celui de genève et comme rien
n'est trop beau
des colonnes de buren un artiste renommé
agrémentent l'esplanade de l'hôtel de
ville un projet pharaonique à plusieurs
millions d'euros
adrien mexys on a fait un des principaux
arguments de sa campagne alors choisi de
faire la mairie c'est avoir choisi de ne
pas rénover des écoles de ne pas rénover
des infrastructures c'est avoir fait un
choix dont 28 millions là dedans pour ça
les berges essentiellement des
fonctionnaires et des élus
voilà ça dit beaucoup sur le personnage
et ça fait travailler bien entendu ces
entreprises favorite mais le maire
sortant à préparer sa réplique
et elle est cinglante sur son blog
françois bernardini a publié des photos
évoquant le passé sulfureux d'un jeune
homme se trouvant sur la liste d'adrien
mexys ce candidat est accusé d'être un
néonazi la nouvelle a filtré jusque dans
la presse locale
nous montrons l'article à adrien mexys
et à une partie de son équipe
oui j'ai lu ouais bah oui c'est la
rétracte la tactique des boules puantes
il n'y a absolument rien d'avéré là
dedans moi ça me c'est quelqu'un qui de
toute façon effectivement et en étant
faite en fin de liste qui n'est pas
qu'on n'a pas vraiment vu pendant
pendant la campagne mais bon moi je les
ai eus au téléphone s'est pas fait pas
partie d'un groupe il ya aucune preuve
qu'il fasse partie d'un moment je pense
que c'est un encore une fois c'est un
c'est une tactique de fin de campagne
pour essayer de salir la liste moment il
faut revenir un petit peu sur terre là
il faut arrêter de mélanger tout ça et
de faire le jeu de certains me semble de
quoi vous parlez là eh ben les villas
les les fascistes et tout ce qu'on veut
quoi il faut arrêter c'est cette image
c'est pourtant bien ce candidat que l'on
voit ici à droite sur cette vidéo
manier le sabre anthony de parra sur
fond de musique militaire
c'était il y a deux ans
le candidat faisait alors partie d'un
groupe extrémiste appelé national
bolchévique qui se revendique du
communisme et du fascisme leurs idées
leurs propos incitent à la haine raciale
et vise particulièrement la communauté
maghrébine au début de sa campagne
adrien eksi s'est laissé photographier à
ses côtés pouvait-il ignorer son
engagement radical
même la famille du colistier l'aurait
découvert en lisant le journal
le jeune homme s'était montré discret
soul et toulouse jésus lui cycliques
photo le mélange qui sont des
communistes l'autre comme devant l'autre
depuis voilà le trompettiste soudan a
dit on tout ça c'est ce qu'ils au 18 ans
au front national
à la limite jocko comprend là on sait
qu'ils trop loin c'est logique et
rationnel et trucs le nude tous autant
qu'ils sont venus et nous avons cherché
à joindre le jeune homme qui n'a pas
souhaité nous répondre
pour adrien hexis ces révélations
entachent sérieusement sa stratégie d'un
front national au dessus de tout soupçon
comment les électeurs d'istres vont ils
réagir dans les urnes d'ici quelques
jours
à tarascon dans un petit appartement du
centre ville
une famille a fait son choix elle votera
front national comme au premier tour
pour janine et sa fille elodie 20 ans
les fins de mois sont difficiles de
l'arrivée des parts des jeux jeanne une
vie avec seulement 400 euros de rsa par
mois avec ses maigres revenus
elle tente d'aider ses deux filles qui
sont intérimaires toutes les trois
contes sur le front national pour
améliorer leurs conditions de vie pour
moi les faits divers mais forte d'une
crise valeureux dire ça mais l'hiver
mais toi pour que nous français en piste
de russie le canada la france a fait
puisque vous attendez coup droit à grand
chose
il conduisait marine le pen la dernière
fois quand elle voyage en italie et le
sentir en italie quand elle voyagera au
maroc elle ne saturent au maroc et quand
elle vient en france à le sentir en
france et pas à l'étranger autour de la
table les amis des filles voteront eux
aussi pour le front national
jeanine qui a des origines tigane estime
avoir tout fait pour s'intégrer et elle
aimerait que beaucoup face comme elle
j'étais le caravan par rapport à mes
filles j'ai voulu que le zaï à l'école
et que ne soit pas maltraités parce que
les gens qui vivent en caravanes sont
très mal vus donc que j'ai dit je vais
me trouver un appartement
eh bien regardez ce qu'est la zone l'air
de voyous est ce qu'ils ont l'air de
devenir dépravé saison n'ont pas ce qui
me gêne à tarascon j'ai toussé
maghrébine qui aiguise se promène en
couleur locale si vous êtes français
eh bien vous vivez à la mode française
mais ce qui pousse le plus jeanine à
voter front national c'est l'insécurité
qu'elle dit vivre dans son quartier elle
ne sort plus le soir sans être équipés
enola chanel mais là c'est bon allez hop
je sors pas sur un bouton les arts oui
on sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
elle n'a pourtant jamais eu à s'en
servir
d'ailleurs en 2013 la délinquance dans
les rues de tarascon a baissé de 11% par
rapport à l'année précédente
mais ceux qui vivent dans un quartier
défavorisé ne réagissent pas tous comme
jeanine
dans la petite cité des ferrages un
retraité se refuse à voter front
national bien malgré la saleté et les
nombreuses dégradations qui le met en
rogne seul talent et sa solidité et il
méritait débat
raymond qui est président de la
copropriété fait chaque matin son petit
tour d'inspection et en trente ans il a
vu son quartier se dégrader début d'un
incendie dans un local tags dans les
cages d'escaliers faire la cage
européenne pour les copropriétaires le
coût des réparations avoisine les 20
mille euros par an et puis il y à la
saleté qui exaspère la femme de ménage
certainement
les gens qui sourient de da les couloirs
et j'y suis habitué mêmes moyens non
gras le boulot mais vous avez le droit
guy si vous avez des jouets vous avez de
tout ce n'est pas normal
il ya deux possibilités les gens ne
respecterions tout se fait vive le vote
front national
ils se rabattront sur le front national
ça 6-7 6 sur l'autre du front national
est basée sur l'ignorance de sur la
facilité de toucher des gens qui sont
ignorants beaucoup de choses ils
s'imaginent que le front national va
donner la fessée et ça va être le
paradis s'imaginent qu'ils ont un
secours alors que ce secours les
terrains par le fonds
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là à istres à quelques
jours du deuxième tour
adrien makes his vient de recevoir un
soutien de poids celui de sa maman
car chez eux la politique est une
affaire de famille vous avez le sourire
catherine est aussi candidate fn à aix
en provence mais bel et bien parce que
c'est le deuxième tour je suis content
d'être au deuxième tour et parce que
adrien et au deuxième tour
pourtant qu'ils soient au deuxième tour
et je ne vais pas pousser bien au
contraire car on a toujours des craintes
pour c est donc je les bats poussée du
tout ouais je pense que tu étais plutôt
inquiète que voilà maintenant c'est bon
parce qu'il remet en cause quand même
toute une trajectoire professionnelle
adrien mexys a d'abord adhéré à l'ump
puis il bascule au front national il ya
cinq ans le déclic il a eu alors qu'il
accompagnait sa mère un meeting j'ai
fait campagne dans l'eure à côté de
marie dès que j'ai invité adrien des
dons qu'il l'a rencontré
oui on nous croyait avoir loupé elle
s'est arrêtée et elle a baissé la vitre
et on est venu et c'était très bien on a
une demi heure ensemble c'était très
intéressant à l'est entre eux bien sa
maman l'a accompagné à la
sous-préfecture où il doit déposer sa
liste pour le second tour
mais le candidat prend semble-t-il un
peu trop de temps et il est vite rappelé
à l'ordre
absolument pour lui tout a brûlé
c'est maintenant vous savez aussi jamais
y avait le moindre problème la date
limite leurs limites ces six heures faut
absolument qu'ils mènent
la veille dès 15h50 et alors et alors il
y avait un problème s'il faut aller
faire des trucs
or faut vraiment qu'il y aille jusqu'au
bout vous veillez sur lui non non pas du
tout mais là parce que je suis là je
serai pas là j'y penserais pas et
puisque je suis là c'est une maman c'est
normal quand adrien mexys entre à la
sous préfecture
il croise son équipe qui en ressort
toute la journée avec leur matériel
ils ont imprimé des centaines de listes
de noms ces listes pourraient bien faire
basculer les élections en leur faveur
voilà ce que vous avez été on a copié
les listes des abstentionnistes et ça va
vous servir à quoi ça allait voir avec
eux de manière à pouvoir leur demander
déjà pourquoi ils n'ont pas été votées
et puis et puis pourquoi pas les inciter
à voter pour nous la démarche est légale
mais le travail qui les attend est
titanesque
ils doivent convaincre les 900
abstentionnistes de voter pour eux
charles lui commence parce qu'il connaît
dans la liste j'avais pas voter
bon deuxième tour ce sera pour quoi il
faut parce que sinon ouais c'est ont eu
cet avis là il faut vraiment qu'on
n'avait pas la joie au moins moi ce mois
à se mobiliser pour aller moi-même pour
me rendre service et on dira ça pour
l'emporter charles est prêt à tout bon
et vous avez terminé il veut même appelé
des électeurs qui à priori ne voteront
jamais pour eux on n'a pas filmé n'a pas
fait le front de gauche non ou se
prolonge par principe il voit pour
berlin on n'a pas compris six pilotes je
pense qu'il ya aucune bora qu'on peut
négliger que je pense que il ya
peut-être des gens de front de gauche
chivu qui peuvent se dire nous ce qu'on
ne veut surtout pas cesser leur dîner
les équipes sont fatiguées un peu je
pense qu'on est motivé c'est ça qui
compte après la fatigue on aura le temps
de dormir après la campagne
pourquoi la mairie la soirée va être
longue
ils sont plusieurs à vouloir commander
japonais mais il y en a un qui
rechignent situation commande quelque
chose certains talents tels pas le
poisson cru écoute
est ce que j'ai déjà mangé du poisson
c'est comme ça que notre candidature
dimanche 30 mars à istres pour le second
tour adrien mexys et lever aux aurores
ce soir il sera peut-être le nouveau
maire en attendant il est encore
colleurs d'affichés elles ont été une
nouvelle fois arraché pendant la nuit
google ouais effectivement oui moi je
crois qu'on peut arriver premier ce soir
le candidat est confiant mais il a une
obsession il est persuadé que l'équipe
du maire va tenter de tricher pour
remporter l'élection
dans chaque bureau de vote il a placé
ses lieutenants pour surveiller les
faits et gestes des électeurs il faut
que tu
tu regardes bien sur leurs prix à la
carte électorale est juste on connaît
tokyo sur garde que c'est bien la
personne doit incarner endettés oui
voilà en fait
en fait vous êtes super méfiant disons
que c'est le deuxième tour donc il ya
des raisons de penser que c'était
suffisamment décisif pour que qu'il
faille prendre aucun risque
pourquoi votre avis peu d'erreurs
tricherie oui il peut toujours pendant
ce temps à tarascon valérie lopy va
voter en famille en chemin elle fait une
rencontre dont elle se serait volontiers
passé son rival lucien limousin
mais bien sûr je vais le candidat divers
droite l'a malmenée pendant tout le
second tour visiblement mal à l'aise
valérie lopy encore novice en politique
ne sait pas trop quelle attitude adopter
voilà voilà donc bon je vais continuer
mon chemin
passé ce léger moment de solitude
elle reprend ses esprits et le chemin du
bureau de vote à voter le devoir
accompli
il faut maintenant trouver le moyen de
s'occuper jusqu'au résultat ce soir à 20
heures pour la candidate de tarascon ce
sera l'actualité revu et corrigé par
jean marie le pen
[Musique]
il est 18 heures c'est le moment crucial
du dépouillement pour les deux candidats
qui retiennent leur souffle
à istres pour l'instant le candidat fn
semble faire jeu égal avec le maire
sortant
c'était inespéré
merci à son grand soulagement
les électeurs n'ont pas tenu compte des
révélations de la presse locale sur son
colistier au passé d'extrémistes au
final dans ce bureau de vote
adrien mexys devance le maire sortant de
quelques voix même si ce n'est qu'un
seul bureau sur les 31 le candidat
commence à y croire
si à istres le fn est plus que jamais
prêt du but
à tarascon c'est déjà la grande
désillusion
il est 20 heures
les résultats officiels sont tombés la
défaite est lourde
on est dans le moment de déception ont
redouté et valérie lopy obtenu 47% des
voix contre 53 pour son rival lucien
limousin
une claque pour celles qui se voyait
déjà porté l'écharpé tricolore pour
adrien beauxis à istres en revanche
c'est la standing-ovation on n'avait pas
prévu de champagne même s'il s'est
finalement incliné largement face au
maire sortant
il n'a pas fini
c'est sûr que le début car pour la
première fois à istres sept
représentants fn vont siéger au conseil
municipal et nous voyez en match pas du
halal
[Rires]
à tarascon la défaite de valérie laupies
fêté par ses opposants
jusque devant son qg les vainqueurs sont
venus narguer les perdants et les
esprits s'échauffent
[Musique]
les habitants qui craignait de devoir
quitter le centre ville si valérie lopy
passait sont soulagés
[Musique]
rester à milan
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]